こちらは座の病欠らしくブーブーお茶のペン粒間だ
ハンバーグライスだけじゃは鈴木付を九朔ぞむず
俺がテレビ来なかったアーっていうわけであのこういうの見つけたいんですよ惚れ俺が
見つけたかったけど大崎に見つけられたんで王将がありません
まず見てみましょうペアんぐにコーンスープをぶっかけると魂が震える生まずになる
こと
判明第一に2つ作っていきましょういや俺はねえぺアンズーの姉無限の可能性を分かっ
てるんですけどそういうのがねでっを好きすぎで逆にこのまま食うのがおいしいと思っ
たってるんでしょうね多分普通に食うのがもうベストだと思っちゃってるんでもうその
考え金クリエイティビティじゃないんだろうなことから
いうとき絶対何かしら混ぜてみますいいなぁもうコンポターズ入れたらバッ直側買っ
たっていうのを一番先生に出したら
続いて今後男女をつくっていきましょうなんでもいいですねなんでもいいんですけど
ちゃんとあーもう
4 o ああうばそうなんだけどねちょっと室にコンボだぞ作る過程で言い出しル
ポタージュを入れる部分がないので何かこれに陥るだろう
2で作りますかけます
ちょっと結構濃いめの作りたいねちょっとたしますねん
いやー
はそうよこれ
[音楽]
を
もたくさんとって気がせますもうエエですよお湯を切っています相手をつくってきまし
た
さらにまず普通に焼きそばも作っちゃっていいと思うんだ
なぜかねぇ俺を持った美味しいなぁもうわかってるんでしょたぶんね駅そばにね公募た
汁で食べてればつけて美味しいのはわかってるんですけども
風にめちゃんこおいしくないとやっぱねー
ダメだと思うんですよとだけでももう一個準備したんで普通のペンのまず美味しく食べ
ます僕はなんだって
ペヤングが好きですから
という気で普通の食べるとそこそこお腹が膨れるし
ペヤンヌの味にもちょっとあーってなるんでその状況でえあんなコンポタージュを送っ
て美味しいんで思ったらそれは本当に美味しいですただお腹も結構膨れてるしなかなか
おいしいという言葉が出にくいと思うので果たしてどれくらいパッチックス美味しいの
かっていうちょっと検証していこうと思いますだけでまず普通にいただきます強い食い
たいだけです
いただきますというでこれのさんと待ってる間にも食べましょういただきます
日本10枚結局フツーが一番美味しいというところある
ちそうさまでした最高に美味しかったここで終わりたい気持ちもやまやまですが本日の
メインはこちらこれでいえ感じの満腹感でもうめちゃくちゃペンおいしかってハッピー
エンドなんですけどここでさらにおいしいと言わせたらもう本物ですあなたを認め
ましょう吉真さんとに立ったので覆いを切っていますはい完成します次で早速作って
いきましょうまず
普通にピア劇そばを作る原点にして頂点ね0.2して仰天結局ねぇレストアーサーの
器楽ですよ俺は俺は何の味付けもしねぇ
生粋なお目が一番好き着色もねー
そんなオメガ番手でコースに出てきますねほんとにおれしらんぜ
ああ
やっぱり待って本当に f うううううあああ
て切ってねーことを入れちゃいまーですねこれ待って本当に大丈夫これ
た
チキンラーメンぽい感じがありますけれどもうまいかどうかは別の話です
いただきますまだまだこれで美味いって言ったら本当に凄いですからねこれで埋めって
本当に本物においしいと思いますでは
ております
[音楽]
うまっ
me
あっはぁ
やばい
めっちゃ臭ないかもしれないじゃん中ないんだこれなんだろなんかやんがソースと
コーンスープがうまい子と噛み合っててすごくまろやかで優しい味わいになっており
ます
ああ
これ食べたら眠気ならな何だろうこれやばいがいろいろ日出てきたんですけども結構に
好きな人期待ない人って分かれると思うのが多かったんですけど今回のはたぶんみんな
結構好きだと思います
馬なんだろうチキンラーメン焼きそばと名付けましょう私が名前をつけるとしたらこう
いうのを作れて